[Applaus]
[Musik]
heute werden wir über das thema sprechen
auf dass ihr alle gewartet habt den post
corona haushalt der europäischen union
ok button holt sich gleich ab haye und
duda schlag nicht ein ich weiß dass es
sich die das langweiligste thema der
welt anhören mag über budgetfragen der
eu zu räsonieren aber wir reden hier
über einen der größten öffentlichen
ausgaben pläne der weltgeschichte
[Musik]
über einen zeitraum von mehr als sieben
jahren und europa mehr als zwei
billionen euro ausgeben und ja ich meine
zwei deutsche billionen also zwei
englische brilliance so viel geld in so
kurzer zeit wird nur ganz ganz selten
verschleudert sperre also dann ist auch
schon lieber weit auf denn was meinst du
woher dieses ganze geld kommen wird nun
wenn du dir dieses video aus einem
eu-land ansieht wird es direkt aus
deiner tasche kommen und wahrscheinlich
auch noch aus den taschen deiner kinder
kindes kinder und kindeskinder kinder
wir sprechen hier über ein thema das
tiefgreifende folgen für unser leben
haben wird sowohl was die verteilung
dieser gigantischen summe angeht als
auch deren finanzierung glaubt mir du
wirst im laufe dieses videos deinen
augen und ohren nicht trauen und von
emotionen geschüttelt werden mit anderen
worten das alles mag auf den ersten
blick langweilig erscheinen aber fakt
ist du solltest wirklich darüber
bescheid wissen wenn du verstehen willst
wie europa tickt und was in den nächsten
jahren um dich herum abgehen wird welche
fragen werden wir heute also hierzu
angehen nun erstens warum sich die
europäische union gerade jetzt zu diesem
zeitpunkt so viel geld ausgeben 2 wohin
wird dieses ganze geld fließen und
drittens ist das alles überhaupt eine
gute idee oder stehen da vielleicht vor
einer neuen ära des sogenannten klüngel
kapitalismus ganzes ungeahnten ausmaßes
all diese fragen werden wir heute
angehen und beantworten aber zuerst
müssen wir unseren eigenen haushalt
etwas aufpeppen und hilfe unseres
großzügigen sponsor social bpm der
dieses video möglich gemacht hat so
aufschlag ist ein wirklich sicheres vpn
dass die der datenverkehr noch meter
oder verbindungsdaten mit lockt
natürlich könnt ihr mit dessen hilfe
auch website und internet zugreifen die
in dem land in dir gerade seid nicht
verfügbar sind ohne zensur und für block
in ob daheim oder im urlaub mit flex und
andere streaming dienste die ihre
inhalte nur in den usa anbieten von
europa ausnutzen mit serve sagt kein
problem darüber hinaus gilt ist jedoch
auch eine menge sicherheitsfeatures
tagtäglich zum beispiel auch ein
mulmiges gefühl durch die
allgegenwärtigen ups und cookies mit
surf schlag bekommt ihr ein handliches
tool namens clean web dass sie alle
bloggt und die damit verbundenen
gefahren beseitigt aber nicht nur das
mit noch einem server konnte könnt ihr
alle eure geräte im vpn registrieren
handys notebooks und sogar euren smart
tvs deckt wirklich alle arten von
geräten ab ihr bekommt einen lückenlosen
schutz so und damit das ganze noch mehr
spaß macht bekommt ihr von surf shop
auch einen rabatt von 83% und obendrein
noch die ersten vier monate gratis dazu
wenn ihr den rabattcode politik.de
angeblich zu diesem angebot findet ihr
der beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los besorgt euch surfer und
greift damit auch gleichzeitig uns
finanziell unter die arme so und jetzt
ab nach brüssel das neue babylon der
geldverschwendung
[Applaus]
die kenianische formel
ich weiß was ihr euch alle fragt warum
will die europäische union gerade jetzt
so viele ausgabenprogramme herausbringen
nun tatsächlich ist die europäische
union damit nicht alleine die usa haben
angekündigt dass sie die öffentlichen
ausgaben massiv erhöht werden und viele
andere länder planen dasselbe zu tun
alle staaten scheinen zurzeit ein
regelrechtes wettrennen im geldausgeben
gestartet zu haben ein wettrennen wie
ist die welt noch nicht gesehen hat und
du wirst dich fragen was der grund dafür
ist also wir befinden uns in einer
einzigartigen situation eine schwere
wirtschaftskrise ausgelöst durch eine
gesundheitskrise und eine in der
modernen geschichte noch nie dagewesenes
serie globaler shutdowns des
wirtschaftlichen und gesellschaftlichen
lebens und diese können sich jederzeit
wiederholen denn die gesundheitssysteme
der industrieländer sind nach wie vor
kaum saisonal skalierbar und kann daher
derzeit durch mutationen des corona
virus oder irgendeine neue epidemie
lahmgelegt werden in zwei jahren
pandemie wurde nicht nur nichts dagegen
unternommen dieses engpass risiko zu
beseitigen im gegenteil der mangel an
pflegepersonal wird immer größer und die
gesundheitssysteme ersticken an der
überbordenden maßnahmen bürokratie dies
alles trifft auf die unaufhaltsamen
zunehmende alterung der an immer mehr
zivilisationskrankheiten leidenden
bevölkerung deren gesundheitlicher fall
sowohl körperliche als auch psychischer
natur doch tatkräftig unterstützt wird
[Applaus]
durch lockdown bedingten aktivitäts und
bewegungs rückgang das schüren von
ängsten und panik und die immer stärker
werdende soziale isolation und spaltung
nun könnte man als halbwegs logisch
denkender mensch glauben unsere
politiker würden diese probleme nun
lösen wollen indem sie die ursachen an
der wurzel packen das sieht das
gesundheitssystem endlich skalierbar
machen damit es langfristig gewappnet
ist und durch saisonale
atemwegserkrankungen nicht an seine
grenzen getrieben wird warum
pflegeberufe nicht endlich wirklich
attraktiv machen durch eine üppige
aufstockung der gehälter eine radikale
verbesserung der arbeitsbedingungen eine
breit angelegte ausbildungsoffensive und
mit üppigen gehältern meine ich wirklich
üppig oder banker niveau üppig so dass
ich meinen krankenpfleger kumpel so
richtig beneiden müsste für seinen job
und sein porsche den er sich von seinem
corona bonus zugelegt hat denn allein
die tatsache dass dieser letzte satz ein
witz sein muss zeigt schon in welch
tragische kranken system wir leben eine
weitere lösung könnte zum beispiel eine
art gesundheits zivildienst sein mit dem
man hunderttausende ausgebildeter pflege
reservisten in der bevölkerung vorhalten
könnte und auf der anderen seite könnte
man auch millionen von menschen aus den
risikogruppen für schwere verläufe und
lässt euch einkommen herausholen durch
breit angelegte präventionsprogramme und
die rigorose sanktionierung der
hauptursachen für
zivilisationskrankheiten rauchen zucker
alkohol und bewegungsmangel dies wäre
natürlich ein längerfristiges
unterfangen aber angesichts der
unaufhaltsam alterung der gesellschaft
umso wichtiger denn überleg mal vor der
gesundheitskrise und den shutdowns liegt
die wirtschaft ja prächtig würde man
also fokussiert und zielgerichtet die
ursachen der gesundheitskrise beseitigen
würde es diese wirtschaftskrise gar
nicht geben und dann würde noch
unzählige menschenleben dabei retten
klar würde das alles sehr viel geld
kosten aber eine solche gesundheits
wende wäre viel günstiger als das was
sich unsere lieben politiker stattdessen
ausgedacht haben denn diese magier der
macht lieben es eher global galaktisch
und abstrakt die eben erwähnten
maßnahmen sind in flüsse konkret zu
verständlich und transparent sie würden
unseren werten interessenvertretern kaum
macht vorteile bringen und daher suchen
sie die antworten lieber bei dem mann
dessen foto du hier gerade sie
das ist john maynard keynes einer der
einflussreichsten
wirtschaftswissenschaftler der
geschichte man könnte sagen dass lord
keynes der vater der modernen
sozialdemokratie ist aber eigentlich hat
seine wirtschaft den parteien quer durch
das politische spektrum beeinflusst ihr
einfluss ist gewaltig und hält noch
immer an im prinzip werden seine formeln
auch heute noch fast buchstabengetreu
angewendet obwohl er bereits 1950
verstarb
[Musik]
und was schlug dieser gute mann vor nun
kann es verstand aus die wirtschaft ein
rad ist das nicht angehalten werden wer
seiner meinung nach beste weg aus einer
krise ist die party am laufen zu halten
reaktivieren den konsum mit allen
nötigen mitteln whatever it takes und
wenn private unternehmen und bürger
nicht mehr konsumieren können dann
sollte dies idealerweise der staat tun
schließlich kann sich der staat
jederzeit verschulden die steuern
erhöhen oder einfach sein eigenes geld
drucken natürlich haben alle diese
entscheidungen konsequenzen aber weniger
whatever it takes die keynesianische
theorie besagt also salopp gesagt dass
der staat in zeiten der rezession geld
ausgeben muss diese ausgaben schaffen
neue arbeitsplätze die wiederum dazu
führen dass die menschen geld in der
tasche haben um dinge bei privaten
unternehmen zu kaufen plötzlich kommt
das geld wieder in bewegung und die
wirtschaft wird auch das laute geholt
aber nicht nur das private unternehmen
investieren geld in das was profitabel
ist und das kommt nicht immer dem
gemeinwohl zugute der staat kann jedoch
beschließen geld wird dinge auszugeben
die für alle gut sind wissenschaft
innovation öffentliche dienstleistungen
klingt das nicht herrlich er könnte
gegen so eine tolle politik sein im
prinzip könnten die chinesischen formel
die endgültige lösung für alle großen
wirtschaftlichen probleme seien weder
kommunismus noch der absolut freie markt
bringt uns nach utopia sondern kennen
sie an ismus die perfekte ehe zwischen
wirtschaft und staat klingt zu gut um
wahr zu sein wie du dir vorstellen
kannst gibt es schon wieder einen
nervigen haken bei der ganzen geschichte
ich bin halt ein spielverderber aber ist
hall bitte nicht ich werde an einem
beispiel erklären warum ich mal wieder
der kreis sein muss also lasst uns als
kleine entschädigung für diese herbe
enttäuschung kurz nach spanien reisen
ins jahr 2009 das ist gar nicht so lange
her geld
[Musik]
spanien war eine siegerländer die von
der finanzkrise 2008 am stärksten
betroffen waren in weniger als zwei
jahren verdoppelte sich die
arbeitslosenquote und während dieser
harten zeiten machte der damalige
ministerpräsident josé luis rodríguez
zapatero die wichtigste ankündigung
seiner karriere stalker schichte daraus
besteht der spanische plan zur
ankurbelung von wirtschaft und
beschäftigung den wir ab heute plan
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
plan klingt wie ein plus aus einem
drittklassigen science fiction oder
agentenfilm nun die spanier kam sich am
ende auch vor wie im falschen film wenn
weniger jahre gab spanien zwischen 12
und 50 milliarden euro aus und ja ich
weiß das ist eine sehr große spanne aber
selbst heute ist es schwer zu berechnen
wie hoch die gesamtkosten von planet
tatsächlichen barren transparenz
mangelware und jetzt wirst du dich
sicher fragen ob dieses nur für spanien
eine menge geld war zum vergleich
spanien hat im selben jahr 2009
insgesamt ohne
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
198 milliarden euro steuern eingenommen
das heißt plötzlich gab der spanische
staat geld aus als gäbe es kein morgen
und du wirst sagen geht es denn so
einfach die regierung bringt muss nicht
an geld auszugeben nur um das geld
ausgeben will
[Musik]
nun so lächerlich es auch klingen mag ja
genau so war es im grunde genommen haben
alle spanische städte in den jahren des
planet einfach mal ihre straßen neu
gepflastert das stadtmobil erneuert und
auf jeden kreisverkehr eine mehr oder
weniger geschmack von der statue
aufgestellt vergesst nicht dass es ganz
bewusst kein konkretes ziel gab es
handelte sich nicht um einen plan um
krankenhäuser zu renovieren und weil sie
veraltet waren es ging auch nicht
gezielt darum die infrastruktur zu
verbessern
nein das ziel heißt ausgaben zu
generieren um arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
und die wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln
deshalb konnte jedes noch so lächerliche
projekt gefördert werden beispiel
gefällig das öffentliche thermalbad in
der hauptstadt ist seit eineinhalb
jahren geschlossen die anlage die mit
mitteln aus dem gebaut wurde und 959
euro verschlangen wurde nie eröffnet und
ich weiß dass viele von euch jetzt
denken wo ist das problem ok in der
stadtverwaltung gibt eine million euro
aus um ein bad zu bauen dass am ende
niemand benutzt aber was spielt das für
eine rolle in der stadt kredite bis ins
unendliche und darüber hinaus aufnehmen
kann nun ja es stimmt staaten können
sich mehr geld leihen als familien- oder
unternehmen das geht bis zu einem
gewissen punkt
[Musik]
und spanien hat staatsanleihen
ausgegeben als gäbe es kein morgen denn
in der zwischenzeit waren die spanischen
medien zu sehr damit beschäftigt über
andere heiße themen zu berichten die sie
für wichtiger hielten worüber genau die
nation damals aufgeregt und vom
wesentlichen abgelenkt wurde weiß ich
nicht mehr genau aber nur falls du es
nicht weißt auch in spanischen gibt es
mittlerweile ein äquivalent zur
deutschen gender sternchen analog zum
gender stern-center doppelpunkt und
gender gap gibt es im spanischen das ebt
oder ex zeichen und die varianten um das
weibliche a- oder dass manche werden oft
um ein neutrales endung ergänzt aber ist
amigo oder amiga wird also ein paar
ein guter alter amiga 500 diese also
schön gender neutral amiga 500 super
interessant nicht wahr aber zurück zu
viel langweiligeren thema unseres videos
das auch damals schon kaum jemanden in
spanien interessiert hat wenn es jedoch
interessiert hat waren die
internationalen investoren die spanien
geld geliehen hatten denen ist gender
sprechen nämlich schnurzpiepegal außer
es würde irgendwie rendite abwerfen tut
es aber nicht die anleger an den bond
märkten wurden also immer weniger
zuversichtlich dass der spanische staat
geliehenen gelder zurückzahlen konnte
und was passiert wenn die investoren die
ihr nicht trauen oder dreizehnter juni
2012 moody's stuft spanien auf eine
stufe über ramschniveau herab mit
anderen worten spanien schuldete so viel
geld das ist echt schwierig wurde es
irgendwann zu zahlen und da niemand
spanien vertraute verlangten die
investoren höhere zinsen um dieses
risiko zu kompensieren wenn ich eine
vorstellung zu geben es gab jahre in
denen allein die zinszahlungen den zweit
größten ausgabenposten im staatshaushalt
ausmachten plötzlich hörten die medien
auf sich um triviale probleme zu kümmern
und begannen darüber zu diskutieren wie
sehr spanien bank ort war nun wenn das
kind schon in den brunnen gefallen war
glaubt mir eine ähnliche krise bist du
in deinem land nicht durch leben
und ich weiß dass viele von euch denken
markt das ist eben spanien ein
paradebeispiel für schlecht gemanagte
staatsausgaben wahrscheinlichsten
spanischen politiker korrupt und haben
einfach nicht die richtigen experten
konsultiert solche zustände kann man
sich auf die ganze eu übertragen nicht
vorstellen in brüssel es ist nun doch
vollprofis jedes land schickt dort doch
nur die besten der besten hin oettinger
von allein alles über kompetente
fachleute in deren karrieren sich die
erfolge nur so aneinander reihen
deswegen sind sie doch bis nach brüssel
gekommen an die absolute spitze kommt
diesmal müssen wir uns wirklich keine
sorgen machen die gigantischen
ausgabenprogramme werden von den
klügsten köpfen europas beaufsichtigt
menschen die genau wissen wo und wie sie
diese zwei billionen euro am
effizientesten ausgeben können alle über
optimal systems das wort gibt es nicht
aber egal diesmal geht es bestimmt nicht
um ein ausgehendes ausgeben wildes oder
comics mit das ist diesmal anders ist
bitte bitte und ich sage dir und ein
popcorn und genießt einfach was jetzt
kommt
[Musik]
europas helikopter geld
bevor wir fortfahren müssen wir eine
kleine anmerkung machen die haushalte
der europäischen union werden für die
nächsten sieben jahre im voraus
genehmigt mit anderen worten die soeben
verabschiedeten haushalte decken den
zeitraum von 2021 bis 2027 und lassen
sich in drei bereiche unterteilen den
ordentlichen haushalt er sich auf 1,1
millionen euro beläuft dann gibt es noch
den schul mechanismus bei denen jene
unternehmen unterstützt werden die am
meisten unter den lock downs gelitten
haben und schließlich ist da noch die
mutter aller staatsausgaben einen posten
namens next generation eu mit nochmals
750 milliarden euro worum es dabei geht
nun das ist so etwas wie das große
glücksspiel der eu die idee hinter
diesem ausgabenprogramm ist ist europa
zum grünsten digitalen ganzheitlich
ssten und 2.0 ist ein kontinent der welt
zu machen und das führt zu dem was wir
die große europäische
feuerwehrspritze nennen können das
größte ausgabenprogramm in der
geschichte der eu mehr als zwei
millionen euro sollen in den nächsten
sieben jahren ausgegeben werden und ja
wir sprechen hier noch immer von
deutschen billionen
[Musik]
um das ganze ins rechte licht zu rücken
dieser betrag ist was sieben mal so hoch
wie die gesamte rettungsaktion
griechenland während der euro krise und
was wurde damals für ein aufheben darum
gemacht wochen lang wurde verhandelt
kronen gestritten nächtliche marathon
sitzungen abgehalten die medien sowohl
in griechenland als auch in den
geberländern des nordens liefen heiss
mit diesem thema tja und jetzt haben es
mit einer ausgaben orgie zu tun die
sieben mal so groß ist wisst ihr was sie
wollte so eben ganz geschmeidig
abgesegnet ohne dass irgend jemand auch
nur die geringste debatte geführt hat ok
schon passiert keine ursache jetzt
bleibt also nur die frage übrig wie das
alles bezahlt werden soll nun ich denke
du christ die antwort bereits vorstellen
europäisches parlament stimmt für neue
steuern in der eu zur rückzahlung der
konjunktur anleihen aber reicht es
wirklich aus nur neue steuern zu erheben
um all diese ausgaben zu finanzieren
offensichtlich nicht europa braucht geld
und zwar sofort und was machen staaten
der sich schnell geld brauchen und ich
denke die antwort darauf kannst du dir
wahrscheinlich auch schon denken
die eu begibt die größte anleihen einzel
crash zur finanzierung des post korrekt
wiederaufbaus die europäische union sind
mit ihrer ersten next generation
eu-anleihe ein starkes signal zur
unterstützung einer grünen digitalen und
verantwortungsvollen erholung das ist
richtig plötzlich ist das was einst das
große tabuthema in der europäischen
union war realität geworden eurobonds
und warum waren eurobonds ein tabuthema
in der eu wir haben vor allem jahr ein
video dass du auf diese politik er
stellt den link findest du in der
beschreibung sie dir dieses video ruhig
noch mal an um zu begreifen in welcher
welt wir jetzt leben ach ja und vergisst
du dich das abo um keines unserer videos
mehr zu verpassen dankeschön aber zurück
zu den eurobonds das problem mit ihnen
ist dass sie den mitgliedstaaten die
verantwortung für die begleichung der
schulden abnehmen mit anderen worten
ländern mit niedriger bonität wie
spanien oder griechenland verlassen sich
auch die zuverlässigeren länder in
europa wie deutschland oder die
niederlande weil das könnte eine gute
idee sein wenn die europäischen
haushalte von brüssel aus ruhe gesetzt
würden aber die realität sieht anders
aus in wahrheit stellt die europäische
union muss geld zur verfügung es in den
mitgliedstaaten die entscheiden wofür es
ausgegeben wird wie wird dieses geld
also verteilt wird es gleichmäßig
verteilt wird es nach der
bevölkerungsdichte verteilt ganz und gar
nicht schon einmal diese grafik an
hier kannst du sehen dass spanien der
unangefochtene gewinner dieser
klassenlotterie ist es erhält mehr als
15 der gesamten europäischen mittel und
nein die meisten dieser gelder werden
nicht von brüssel verteilt sondern von
madrid aus und das funktioniert
folgendermaßen die mich diese länder in
diesem fall spanien legen brüssel einen
ausgabenplan vor brüssel belegt ihn und
bezahlte alle rechnungen mit anderen
worten nationale politiker können die
lorbeeren dafür einheimsen dass sie das
geld im überfluss ausgeben während die
schuldenuhr steuerlast von ganz europa
getragen wird aber eigentlich am meisten
von den wirtschaftsstarken länder neben
norden des kontinents
[Musik]
und ich weiß was viele von euch denken
so einfach kann es doch nicht sein wir
reden hier von der europäischen union
dem ort an dem die klügsten köpfe der
welt politik zusammenkommen es gibt doch
sicher eine menge kontrollen um zu
verhindern dass das gute geld der eu
steuerzahler ihrer kinder kindes kinder
und kindeskinder sinnlos verbraten wird
oder gar in irgendwelchen dunklen
kanälen versickert oder diesmal hat
brüssel doch bestimmte
sicherheitsmechanismen eingebaut um
einen mega viel wie spaniens
katastrophalen kleine zu verhindern nun
formell ja die europäische union scheut
keine kosten und mühen um den anschein
zu erwecken sie würden mit aller härte
sicherstellen dass in allen
mitgliedsländern rechtsstaatlichkeit und
mechanismen zur korruptionsbekämpfung
herrschen das erklärt nämlich
schlagzeilen wie diese die europäische
kommission ist bereit polens
konjunkturprogramm bereits im november
zu genehmigen wenn warschau bestimmten
rechtsverbindlichen zielen zur
wiederherstellung der
rechtsstaatlichkeit zustimmt mit anderen
worten die eu hat sich polen trifft und
gesagt ich werde euch bei euren anteil
an den geldern nicht geben wenn ihr
nicht bereits ein zu garantieren dass
sie nicht in den händen der freunde der
regierung gelangten und viele von euch
denken vielleicht dass dies nur der
endgültige beweis dafür ist dass man in
brüssel weiß wie man öffentliche gelder
aus gibt aber andere werden vielleicht
glauben dass sich die eurokraten gezielt
polen als sündenbock herausgepickt haben
weil ihnen die dortige regierung ein
dorn im auge ist während sie bei den
eigenen amigos in madrid paris rom und
berlin alle hühneraugen ganz fest zu
drücken nun die frage ob diese kontrolle
mich hat es nun wirklich ausreichend ist
durchaus angebracht und warum das werden
wir uns jetzt mal genauer ansehen lasst
uns dazu doch einfach noch mal jenes
land reisen dass die meisten gelder aus
diesem budget erhalten wird aber diesmal
die gegenwart also alle abs
spanien ist anders oder vielleicht doch
nicht
wie bereits gesagt ist spanien der
größte nutzen ich seit dieser
europäischen wohltaten und ist auch
eines der ersten länder das seinen
ausgaben plan vorgelegt hat dieser plan
mit dem aufbruchstimmung verbreiten
namens training kennt durch soll zeigen
wie die spanische regierung den mehr als
140 milliarden euro ausgeben will die
sie von der eu bekommen wird du kannst
ihn dir auf ihrer website ansehen die
ich dir in der beschreibung verlinken
werde allerdings kann man sich zum
zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses videos
nur wenige ausgaben projekt ansehen was
ist mit dem rest nun wir wissen es nicht
mit anderen worten die europäische union
hat spaniens ausgabenplan genehmigt ohne
dass erst veröffentlicht wurde
transparenz ist also auch jetzt wieder
mangelware denn im dunkeln lässt sich's
besser munkeln und mit wem nun man muss
kein großer prophet sein um
vorherzusagen dass ein neues goldenes
zeitalter für große beratungsfirmen wie
kpmg anrechnet
kpmg revolutioniert die beratung zu
europäischen fonds die spanische
niederlassung von kpmg und local europe
haben eine allianz unterzeichnet um die
umfassende lösung für die beratung zu
europäischen fonds zusammen mit einem
exklusiven technologischen tool
anzubieten dass die identifizierung
bestimmter projekte erleichtert die für
den zugang zu fördermitteln in frage
kommen ganz genau die großen
beratungsunternehmen haben die fette
europäische feuerwehr geldspritze
bereits fest in ihrer hand und wo wäre
sie drauf halten nun schauen wir doch
mal werden am besten mit kpmg vernetzten
kunden sind wer kann es sich denn
überhaupt leisten ihre ausgesprochen
kostspieligen dienste in anspruch zu
nehmen genau nur die großen konzerne
[Musik]
meinst du ich würde hier wieder
irgendwelche vorurteile gegen einen
unbegründeten verdacht schüren dann
warte ab was ich dir jetzt zeige unter
den projekten die öffentlich gemacht
wurden sind zwei besonders auffällig das
eine ist die sanierung von öffentlichen
gebäuden das heißt wenn der plan dazu
diente alle straßen spaniens neue
pflaster wird der neue plan dazu dienen
öffentliche gebäude zu sanieren eine
sache die jeder weiß von oberster
bedeutung zu dem kampf gegen den
klimawandel ist und das entscheidende
schlüsselelement für die transformation
der wirtschaft um sie fit für das 21
jahrhundert zu machen nicht wahr aber
warte denn es kommt noch besser ein
weiterer plan den spanier vorgeschlagen
hat ist trommelwirbel die schaffung
eines audio visuellen hubs das heißt
sparen den satz hatte 200 millionen euro
an subventionen ausgeben um
fernsehserien und videospiele zu
produzieren klar die hat er einem
lockdown ja am meisten gebeutelt geld
und weil heutzutage alles
umweltfreundlich digital ganzheitlich
und 2.0 sein muss gehören zu diesem
projekt auch schmuckstücke wie dieses
hier
die kommission wird einen best practice
leitfaden für eine umweltfreundliche
produktion und dienstleistungserbringung
erarbeiten der ansatz wird schrittweise
erfolgen mit dem ziel das bewusstsein zu
schaffen und die branche zu bringen mit
der umsetzung nachhaltiger lösungen zu
beginn okay wie bitteschön können filme
auf umweltfreundliche und nachhaltige
weise produziert werden wahrscheinlich
bin ich einfach zu dumm und fantasielos
um das zu kapieren aber was für ein
glück ich doch habt das ist die eu gibt
und diese einen ganzen fetten bericht
darüber herausgegeben hat wie man auch
die visuelle produktion grüner machen
kann den ziehe ich mir nachher gleich
rein um mit meinen youtube filmchen in
zukunft nicht mehr das klima zu erwerben
nochmal gutgegangen planet gerettet
[Musik]
und viele von euch werden sich jetzt
fragen wer hat sich dieses ganze geniale
projekt eigentlich ausgedacht denn die
weiteren die produktion fonds serie und
videospielen dieser grünen digitalen
ganzheitlichen und 2.0 transformationen
die europa so sehr braucht nun wer sich
das folgende kleine video aus spanien
ansieht kann schon erahnen wer dahinter
steckt mediapro ist auf der suche nach
einer millionen investition für sein
eigenes audiovisuelles zentrum nach
angaben von experten hat die gruppe mit
der suche nach kapital etwa 500
millionen euro begonnen um ein neues
audio visuelles zentrum in spanien zu
schaffen für diejenigen unter euch die
mediapro nicht kennen es ist eine film-
und fernsehproduktionsfirma mit
bekannten verbindungen zu genau jenen
politischen parteien die gerade jetzt in
spanien an der macht sind ihr präsident
ist der herr den du gerade sie ist sein
name ist die schon mehrere und sein
mediapro steht am rande des bankrotts
das unternehmen hat sogar schon mehrmals
um eine staatliche rettungsaktion
gebeten was für ein zufall dass ich
gerade im richtigen moment die amigos
oder ganz boka miegels der senior es die
auch ganz zufällig in den
regierungsparteien sitzen so ein tolles
projekt wie das der audiovisuellen
drehscheibe europas ausgedacht haben
diese 200 millionen euro aus unseren
taschen sind da sicherlich super
angelegt und pass auf denn das ist nicht
das einzige beispiel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ein richter hebt die blockade der
rettung von plus ultra auf indem er
vorerst keine straftat anerkennt die
fluggesellschaft erhält die 34 millionen
euro die sie für den weiterbetrieb
benötigt in diesem fall geht es um die
rettung einer fluggesellschaft die vier
flüge pro woche anbietet ja du hast
richtig gehört vier flüge die woche
nicht pro flugzeug sondern für die ganze
airline und jetzt halte ich fest bis vor
ein paar monaten wo es noch kaum jemand
freundin ihre existenz aber die
eigentümer dieser fluggesellschaft haben
gewisse verbindungen zu einigen
mitgliedern der regierung und diese hat
keinen moment gezögert ihn aus der
tasche zu helfen natürlich kann diese
rettung vollkommen legal sein
schließlich wurden in zeiten des corona
virus schon viele andere unternehmen
gerettet die frage ist aber ob es sich
wirklich um ein strategisches
unternehmen handelt das gerettet werden
muss wenn plus ultra gerettet wird warum
sollte das nicht auch jedes andere
unternehmen gerettet werden und du wirst
sagen aber moment mal so einfach kann
das doch nicht sein jemand in brüssel
ist doch sicher dafür verantwortlich
dass es keine korruption oder
vetternwirtschaft gibt wenn es darum
geht das gute geld der eu steuerzahler
ihrer kinder kindes kinder und
kindeskinder auszugeben oder schon
wieder ein déjà vu aber ja du hast recht
erst kürzlich wurde eine ganze neue
europäische institution geschaffen ich
für die kontrolle öffentlicher gelder
zuständig ist das european public
prosecutors office kurz epo eine
europäische staatsanwaltschaft gegen
korruption es war also deutlich geworden
dass die machtlosigkeit der bereits
länger bestehenden anti betrugs behörde
olaf den missbrauch von europäischen
geldern quasi straflos stellte das
problem ist jedoch dass die eppo
überlastet ist oder andersrum
hoffnungslos unterbesetzt
[Musik]
denn mehr öffentlich ausgaben bedeuten
viel mehr projekte die kontrolliert
werden müssen nach einer schätzung der
europäischen kommission ist die
arbeitsbelastung neun mal höher als
normal die zahl der ermittler ist jedoch
kaum gestiegen mit anderen worten europa
wird viel neues geld ausgeben außer für
die einstellung von leuten welche die
ausgaben kontrollieren und überwachen
diese werden sich dann wohl nur auf ganz
bestimmte projekte und länder
konzentrieren müssen eben diejenigen
welche von brüssel sowieso als die bösen
angesehen werden tja ein schelm der
böses dabei denkt jetzt aber ist die
frage an dich gerichtet wird die
europäische feuerwehr geldspritzen
europa wirklich grüner nachhaltiger
digitaler ganzheitlicher und mehr 2.0
machen ist dieses mega ausgabenprogramm
wirklich dass das wir jetzt brauchen
oder stehen wir einfach nur vor einer
neuen ära des kapitalismus zwei
billionen euro das ist doch der wahnsinn
welche auswirkungen wird das alles auf
unseren geldbeutel haben werden wir
wieder eine neue schuldenkrise erleben
wie immer sind wir auf alle eure meinung
zu diesem thema schon hochgradig
gespannt ich hoffe also dass euch die
video gefallen hat weil es ja gibt es
mit einem leichten freunden und vergesst
nicht das abo mit glöckchen und keines
unserer videos mehr zu verpassen was gut
und bis bald
[Musik]